good afternoon to everyone and welcome
to this press conference with
commissioner Steven Edie's the press
conference on rescue at the Neo
reinforced European civil protection
mechanism before giving the floor to the
Commissioner let me remind you that we
will also have a technical briefing at
half-past three at the ERC C at the
Emergency Response Coordination Center
in all the emergency room in echo
premises in ho de la loire 86 and you
are invited to attend also this
technical briefing so without further
ado I give the floor to Commission
estimates good afternoon everybody
dear friends resk EU has entered into
force the new legislation strengthening
the European Union Civil Protection so
rescue is now a reality now we have a
piece that completes the pathway the
European system of disaster response is
now stronger more efficient and more
effective fit for purpose for today's
new climate change reality rescue is a
safety net that will be activated when
national capacities and national
resources are overwhelmed dear friends
today rescue calls into action I'm
pleased to announce that we are
launching an initial European
firefighting aircraft fleet differs of
its kind ready for this year's fire
season we are delivering our on our
commitment to upgrade the European civil
production system to be better prepare
to be better equipped and to tackle the
intensity and the complexity of today's
natural disasters fear
we've seen forest fires rage across
Europe from north to south from east to
west fires to not respect porters and
this is why our member states join
forces and made risk EU a reality and
this is why our member state are coming
together to implement a rescue today we
make the first step the first big step
we begin with our rescue initial
transition fleet and as we build up
rescue more assets will follow the
rescue initial assets come on top of the
existing structure of the civil
production mechanism I would like to say
a special thank you to Croatia France
Italy Spain and Sweden the first five
member states to contribute to this
rescue initial transition fleet
direction definitely is an example of
tangible European solidarity this is a
good way to be an engaged member of our
European family conference you know well
that prevention preparedness is key to
an effective response to natural
disasters prevention is always better
than cure it is a universal problem so
our preparedness efforts are not limited
to the rescue initial transition field
we are also reinforcing our monitoring
and coordinating capacities in five
important ways first our emergency
response coordinator Center Coordination
Center year CC working 24/7 has been
reinforced with experts from our Member
States the forest fire support team as
Carlos already said
you will have a chance to visit the GRCC
Center in the afternoon and I'm sure
that our experts there they can answer
any technical questions by you second
point the LCC is stepping up is
coordination role the LCC is
strengthening risk assessment with
participating States especially during
the busy fire seasons third point we
will continue providing satellite maps
through our state-of-the-art copernicus
satellite system to help prevent monitor
and respond to forest fire and of course
to other natural disasters fourth point
we have supported regular field
exercises and training for express and
rescue teams especially in dealing with
forest fires a key component for an
effective response to natural disasters
and fifth last but not least we bolster
collaboration and share best practices
between member states as part of the
newly created knowledge center dear
friends rescue is founded on three
fundamental European values solidarity
protecting European citizens and saving
lives
rescue press key you will foster creator
cooperation and solidarity between our
member state and by twin so we are also
strengthening European integration of
European citizens want European citizens
deserve real solutions to real problems
they want concrete results and rescue
delivers this and also rescue response
to the expectation of our European
citizens of Europeans and we have a
direct a positive impact on their lives
dear friends we are just a few days
before the critical European elections I
strongly believe rest you sends a strong
a clear message to all Europeans
solidarity is not an empty word it's
tangible touching real lives in our
everyday lives and Europe is taking
action concrete action to protect our
citizens and to save lives thank you so
much for your attention
Thank You commissioner and now we can
open the floor for your questions Thank
You commissioner and Abbey scenario from
the Spanish news agency heard about this
and so this initial fleet is for
protecting forest fires I don't know if
you could give us a bit more the next
steps how it will be reinforced to
tackle other natural disasters I
understand the reserve was supposed to
also include things like a field
hospital campaign and others when what
what are the time frames that we're
looking at and my second question would
be if you could precise that the
co-financing rate what's the
co-financing rate that will be for
transport and for the use of this these
equipment and a third question if I may
concerning a prevention you've mentioned
how important it is not only to tackle
the disasters when they happen but also
to prepare in advance the the the cuts
because of the crisis in many member
states understand that Spain was one of
the main programs as well were reduced
so the whole part of the preventive arm
to tackle these things was very heavily
affected I don't know how you see I mean
will this do anything if we don't
actually reinforce the other part I'm
sorry just a quick question with the
initial fleet how many how many fires do
you think you could tackle
simultaneously at the same time
thank you for your questions in the
first of all I would like to emphasize
once again that prevention is one of the
two main pillars of rescue it's really
equal pillar as equipment and this is
why I focus on this that prevention is
better than cure
and without strong prevention
preparedness no equipment is enough this
is my strong and clear message to our
net to our member state and this is why
I strongly believe that we have to focus
on prevention in the business and
through rescue we are strengthened
prevention prepares in three main ways
funding culture of prevention and
knowledge network funding definitely we
strongly support our message to improve
their prevention preparedness even
through risk
EU funding at the same time you know
that European structural funds are
connected and also support prevention
and of course together with innovation
and research funds for example warning
systems drones etc etc and at the same
time through rescue we have to focus on
cultural prevention we have to focus to
see more volunteers more first
respondents on the ground in our member
states so through rescue we can build a
culture of prevention and we can
allocate money in order to see more
volunteers organization of course as I
said we can see together with our member
state how we can improve ourselves about
early warning system education of course
and training and exercise on the ground
with expert and of course as I said
first responders and third point
knowledge Network
prevention preparedness and for all
Member States Spain France Greece Cyprus
Sweden preventional preparers require
common understanding require share
knowledge and expertise we need better
communication network and we need to
share innovative techniques and best
practices across Europe I was in Sweden
two days ago and I saw once again that
the Swedish authorities they realize
after their painful experience last
summer that only through European
solidarity tangible European solidarity
they can deal with this new phenomena
due to climate change so we need each
other and we realize that we are in the
same boat especially in the natural
disasters field this is why we need to
be together
togetherness is not an empty word is
something very concrete especially when
we have to deal with natural disasters -
to climate change look as I said Croatia
France Italy Spain and Sweden they
already decided to contribute in this
initial transition initiative fleet I
strongly believe that with this
transition capacity we can deal with all
forest fires across Europe even
simultaneously our experts they believe
that it is enough and of course as I
said because through race EU we can
increase our coordinating role at the
ERC sea level we can decide decisively
when we face an taneous Li at least
time in order to deploy resources in
order to sell and deliver planes and
helicopters in the area which affected
by forest fires so I think definitely
through rescue even through this initial
transition field we can feel safer in
order to deal with forest fires in the
next sample the question
other measures we've seen a Southbridge
news agency can I ask you in Greek if I
may sir
yeah because we have an injury
interpretation so it's a it's a chance
speak
so a little bit Commission there what do
you think is the significance of resk EU
for countries such as Cyprus with those
characteristics and what could Cyprus
add to the mechanism
what could we contribute and the same of
course question would apply to Greece
I'm certain my mother-tongue
to communicate with my compatriots to
bolian thank you so much for the
question
it is true that Cyprus is in a very
special place when it comes to EU
borders it's in the eastern
Mediterranean and even in this area of
dealing with natural disasters the role
of resk EU well that's an area in which
Cyprus can still contribute to European
solidarity solidarity with other
countries on the southern and
southeastern borders of the EU I know
that the authorities in Cyprus are
seriously considering the option of
participating even in the transitional
phase of resk EU perhaps by contributing
a helicopter or something like that in
June the procedures may be stepped up so
to strengthen the transition fleet
already established and I strongly
believe that Cyprus should participate
must participate for reasons that relate
to its own needs and its own capacity to
deal with fires my compatriots will all
be very aware that some years ago and
because of help from French and Italian
planes that we were able to deal with a
catastrophic fire on the island so
painful experience has shown that aid is
required that you need help to deal with
these situations which are beyond
national capacity to deal with but that
national capacity can also be lent
elsewhere so Cyprus can be a bridge if
you like even in this very difficult
tricky area so with Lebanon Jordan
Israel Palestine Egypt those countries
due to climate change have demonstrably
great needs as well also it sometimes in
relation to flooding so I believe Cyprus
should participate in this exercise
certainly from the transitional phase
and Sur and moving forward it's very
important the Cyprus as well as for
Europe more broadly and I am sure that
this is an opportunity for Cyprus to
show to prove that it is a member of the
European family that gives as well as
taking and of course there will be a lot
of subsidies available as you are aware
risk EU for it's a permanent phase will
be funding 50% of new operational
measures and 75% of a contribution to
thank you so much for this question
because I would like to clarify these
things about the economic cost of rescue
first of all as we clarified with all
our statements from the beginning of
this attempt to persuade our member
state to accept rescue as the new
structure we clarified this no more
bureaucracy no more bureaucracy only
experts from our member states they were
the previous structure had only this new
equipment new structure and
the current Commission proposed for the
next mff Twenty twenty one twenty twenty
seven one point four billion for the
whole cost of Rs ki you in the next MF M
so this is the specific numbers and
figures about the cost of rescue but I
take the opportunity to say a few words
about my approach regarding rescue and
SM definition of the cost effective way
in order to deal with natural disasters
rescue makes economic sense give me the
chance to mention three major reasons
why pain definition rescue is an
insurance policy and protection against
natural disasters is extremely expensive
for any single country so it's an
insurance policy
second point rescue all super in
definition is a risk sharing scheme more
countries that participate greater
benefit for all of us and I think the
last example in Sweden last summer
really really developed country with
assets but could not face forest fires
alone and in my reason in Sweden all
Swedish authorities they recognized that
yes the European solidarity the tangible
so that we is more than necessary even
for sweet and at the same time I have to
say my third point very important for me
rescue is example of economy of scale
and definition of economic scale because
you can understand that it is a
comparative advantage
it is EU added value because we can
provide better production for less money
and definitely through our structure
European Union managed reserve pool of
resources in order to spend less country
by country if we decide to make a
comparison and to think about necessary
resources when we face simultaneously
forest fires across Europe maybe we need
a lot of friends and a lot of
helicopters multiple if we go through
the way over s key you definitely we
need less and this is a special benefit
for our taxpayers so it is economy of
scale it is the European Union added
value and I strongly believe that it's
so obvious for anyone to understand this
and I know well that many of our member
states they already made a fish ability
studies and all of them they agreed on
this rest you it is economic scale for
all of us and this is why we had this
overwhelming majority at the European
Parliament and also at the European
Council
Eleni veteran cat Marigny a commissioner
would you be kind enough to walk us
through the steps let's say there is a
fire in in Greece what are the main
steps that should be taken from Greece
or from any other state and how would it
work out in because I forgot to answer
to with an ASUS about Greece
now I take this opportunity through your
question in order to say more about
Chris yes maybe is better yes anybody
have Olli
there is no doubt that the events in
mathy
you
showed
quite clearly that prevention is of the
essence climate change has brought a new
phenomena which clearly have
catastrophic effects in very short
spaces of time and the events in Madley
were a case in point in Greece in
particular there has to be maximum
utilization of rescue and there has to
be a particular stress on prevention and
readiness everyone I think recognizes
that on all sides of the political
spectrum at the same time I would say
it's also clearly in the interests of a
country as susceptible as Greece to this
type of natural catastrophe to
participate actively certainly in the
permanent phase of rescue but also now
during the transition phase so that it
can access European funding and also put
across the message that yes despite our
problems we are able to contribute to
Hue action and help us to deal with our
common needs and combating in the
context of combating natural disasters
the press conference reminding you I saw
a follow-up
got one more in Greece because we need
to be very specific with this thing
Greece is a country that has severe
danger for wildfires every summer they
know it for decades and decades last
year we have the tragic events in Attica
and mati so bigger thing did you do you
see did you observe any improvement in
their prevention culture since last year
to begin with and do you think that they
do have effective prevention culture
forest fires or the summer but from my
experience and I don't know about the
south of Greece but I know about my
place is healthy there in the north we
had a fire in 2006 nothing changed
nothing not saying what his bearing is
burned and the rest of the forest is
quite unprotected
so how can we pressure them you change
their medallion two traits to prevention
be more proactive
they usually have those you know
civilian planes monitoring the forests
they don't have it now
what can we do
I will continue in in Greek because
the questions about the grease and I
would like to to answer in Greek
language in order to be communicated
with the Greek people in Greek media
sure let's move the semi escapes he's
still in all my visits to Greece
and all my meetings with ministers or
even the President of the Republic I
bring up the matter of forest fire
prevention and the development of
volunteer work and other measures which
would be the most effective in the Greek
context I know that there are efforts
underway our experts at the ER CC are an
ongoing contact with their counterparts
in Greece they provide advice and
know-how they try to help in every
possible way to improve prevention and
readiness and there is obviously the
opportunity for operational means from
Greece to be incorporated into the risky
you but you will be aware that there is
a limit to what the Commission can do we
are limited to contact with the Member
States and encouraging them to improve
prevention the responsibility however
does lie
first and foremost with the Member
States themselves that means that we
have to continue voicing that message
loud and clear about prevention I can't
tell you exactly here and now what has
been done in Greece over perhaps when
you go to the ERC see it through o'clock
the experts will be able to give you
more concrete answers but it's extremely
important that we continue the efforts
and get as many members States on board
as possible with risk EU and of course
rescue you itself will be able to
provide funding for specific measures so
Greece and other member states can rely
on the Commission and they can rely on
the ERC see the coordination center in
the context of their action to improve
their readiness
and whenever anything happens and
whenever requests are lodged we will be
there the same day we couldn't of course
save anyone in a party because it all
happened in the space of two to three
hours but even with the previous system
we were able to help to put out fires in
the Peloponnese and other parts of
Greece with the prior mechanism now the
authorities know that they do have to
improve their record when it comes to
prevention thank you we can hear and as
commissioner just said you will have the
opportunity to meet our experts at
hoppers three at the SEC the Emergency
Response Coordination Center holder
Allah 86 and we will follow now with
media briefing thank you very much